[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
cabinet de conseil le sénat passe à
l'action
en mars les travaux de la commission d'
enquête du sénat sur les cabinets de
conseil ont révélé un phénomène
tentaculaire
sur la seule année 2000 21 plus d'un
milliard d'euros ont été dépensés par
l'état pour des prestations de conseils
devant l'inaction du gouvernement qui
s'est contentée dé fed annonce les
sénateurs ont déposé le 21 juin une
proposition de loi transpartisane visant
à encadrer l'intervention de ces
cabinets dans les politiques publiques
composée de 19 articles le texte des
sénateurs poursuit quatre principaux
objectifs
il s'agit d'abord d'en finir avec
l'opacité des prestations de conseil ce
qui passerait notamment par la
publication annuelle de la liste des
prestations en données ouvertes
le recours aux consultants serait mieux
encadrer avec par exemple l'interdiction
des prestations gratuites qui servent
d'abord la stratégie commerciale des
cabinets
les obligations déontologiques des
cabinets serait renforcée avec un code
de bonne conduite une déclaration
d'intérêts obligatoire et l'exclusion de
tous les cabinets qui ne respectent pas
les règles
enfin les données de l'administration
seraient mieux protégés
cela passerait notamment par une
suppression obligatoire des données
transférées au cabinet à l'issue de la
prestation sous le contrôle de la cnil
pour permettre un examen rapide de la
proposition de loi les sénateurs
demandent à la première ministre
d'inscrire ce texte à l'ordre du jour du
parlement dès le lendemain des élections
législatives
dans l'hypothèse où le gouvernement
refuserait cette demande le texte
pourrait être examinée au sénat à
l'automne
pour en savoir plus consultez le dossier
de presse sur le site du sénat
[Musique]